welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and batches ain't
[ __ ] book clones and kids
episode 13 of the bad batch is now out
and in this video we'll be breaking down
all the easter eggs hidden details
and the things you missed now from here
out it's full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
latest episode then i highly recommend
that you check out now
i also find your lack of likes
disturbing so please drop a thumbs up if
you enjoy the video
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into game of clones
now we start off on odd mantel which is
slowly becoming a base of operations for
the batch
we learn that the mercenaries have been
carrying out missions that were not
privy to
including one in which they encountered
gun docks gundogs have been mentioned
throughout the star wars saga
and these ferocious beasts originate
from bangko you might remember their
name from the empire strikes back when
han said luke looked strong enough to
pull the ears off a gun dock
but outside of this they've also shown
up in the clone wars
now the batch talk about how the area
was swarming with them which
could tie into the title infested
however this usage of the word
goes far beyond that during the episode
the bats travel through tunnels beneath
the planet
and have a slight infestation problem
shall we say
now on top of that mantel seems a lot
more popular than it's been in previous
episodes
and we see that sid has been ousted by a
gangster named roland
roland is a devaronian which is a
species known for their distinctive
horns
he ends up losing one in the episode
which might be a nod to hellboy
but either way it clearly shows his
failings as a criminal
he and his forces completely swarmed the
area and have now overrun it
this kind of shows the order that the
imperials brought to the galaxy
and just as they infested the planets
that they occupied the ones that they
didn't had issues too
the imps were happy to let nefarious
forces overrun things so that they could
either work with the shadowy
organizations
or commander the planet and offer the
people a way that was seemingly better
this power play allowed them to gain
complete control of a lot of systems
as it was either let us take over and
offer order
or take your chances with the gangsters
now sid is okay and we join her back at
the ship
i love how the ithorian and weak way
that we've seen in the bar throughout
also show up here and yeah they're nice
little side characters that constantly
pop up throughout the episode
we learned that roland is uh the son of
izza durand
and that he's been working with the
pikes these are a species of sentient
humanoids that originate from the planet
obadir
however they also supply spice from the
mines of kessel
both spice and kessel get name dropped
in this episode and the former was
actually called that by george lucas as
a note of the book
june which star wars was heavily
inspired by
now you might also recognize the pikes
from solo and sid says roland is using
mantel as a base of operations because
of its connections to multiple
hyperspace routes
with the empire overrunning the galaxy
smuggling is obviously going to become
prevalent
and roland plans to use sid's parlor as
a way to make money
in a time when alternate organizations
were being stumped down
sid somewhat blackmails the group into
helping her and she could have of course
turned the batch over at many times to
the empire
but she refused to sid has learned of a
spice deal between roland and the pikes
and using the mining connections beneath
the planet they head through the
subterranean tunnels
now here i got a lot of flashes of video
games namely
mine chord sections and though i can't
for the life of me find the specific
image that i'm thinking of
there were definitely parts of dead
space that looked very similar to this
also yeah who else is hyped for that
dead space remake
let's go isaac baby now dead space was
of course inspired by aliens
which 2 has had a number of easter eggs
in the season
rekka ends up dropping his torch down
one of the holes and this
causes the earlings to stir it could be
a reference to lord of the rings
namely when that bloody fool of a took
peregrine dropped a bucket in the minds
of mario
back at the bar we see that the
bartender is a pantoran
several of these have appeared in the
show and it's nice seeing the species
getting more attention
especially as george lucas actually
cameoed as one
the weak way leaves some mantel mix in
order to draw the pet ruby out
and this is something that we've seen
rekka and omega eating after celebrating
a successful mission
this was all a distraction to make
roland leave the bar and the group sneak
into sid's office which we see is
infested by
what i believe are womp rats sometimes
warm rats get confused with scurriers
and who am i to tell people that their
star wars knowledge is wrong
especially with the utter rubbish i come
out with in these videos so
if it's not a warm rat just let me know
and
i i i'll i'll block you but i'll be very
grateful
now the batch spice up their life and in
the bar we can see that roland starts
panicking skywalker
amongst the regulars you can also catch
several aliens including a bit
which you'll no doubt recognize from
playing that one song
over and over again in mos eisley the
group go back into the tunnels and we
get a minecart chase that leads to the
earlings coming out too
now shout out simon a birman on twitter
for pointing out that this could also be
a nod to the minecart scene from indiana
jones in the temple of doom
which is also owned by lucasfilm either
way this awakens the hive
and i love how creepy the buildup to
this entire scene is
when they finally appear they avoid the
light and this might be a call back to
the movie pitch black in which the
monsters in that did the same thing
the spice is lost and the two regulars
end up snitching on sid
this is also where we meet the pikes
carrying out the deal
and they're a threatening bunch it must
be said they're the kind of people who
would tell you to smash the like button
and you do it
and rather than waiting until the entire
matter is over sid goes back to the bar
early
and encounters them they want their
spice and take omega hostage
and the batch instead have to head back
to the tunnels in order to get it back
back at the bar we see omega can pretty
much get on with anybody
and learn that roland is very much
trying to impress his parents
this is of course reflected in omega who
has been going above and beyond to live
up to the standard set by the batch
and it's a nice little moment in which i
think we can see some common ground
between the pair
back in the tunnels sid and rekka almost
get the spice out
but they hit a cart on the last crate
and this awakens the earlings even more
also i love how rekka's fear of heights
is constantly brought up in the series
and every time he gets in this kind of
situation the guy just can't handle it
which i actually relate to because i
hate heights as well now using a light
bomb they managed to defeat the hive and
this could be a reference to blade 2
when the titular character
used something similar the pikes keep
their word and allow omega to be
returned to the batch
however they still want to punish roland
and cut off one of his horns
now i don't really care about this guy
so yeah do whatever you want to him
and the group decide to celebrate with a
drink that finishes up the episode
now as for my thoughts on the entry i
really enjoyed it and it's nice to see
that the batch aren't just fighting off
the imperials all the time
and there are other things in the
universe that they must face against
i can't believe that it's been 13 weeks
and the show hasn't really had any duds
in it
each episode builds on the last and
though we often get standalone entries
that work without the interconnectivity
i think that the character development
is the real hawk here
said it once and i'll say it again but
the idea of conformity versus
individuality is rife throughout the
series
whether it's a planet deciding to give
up their freedoms for protection
only in turn to become a fascist state
or a planet that goes against this and
thus has to fight for their freedom
we see it so much throughout the show
anyway a really good episode and
of course love to hear your thoughts on
it in the comments below we've got just
three episodes left so i'm excited to
see what you think is gonna happen next
as we head towards the finale now as a
thank you for commenting you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away three mcu box sets on the
30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we baked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
space jam in which we go over every
single easter egg in it
it was absolutely devastating completely
exhausting video i do
so i really appreciate you heading over
there and just checking it out now
without all the way
thank you for singing through this i've
been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace